[Music]
reel me this what's not a joke but
sometimes you need to shout it twice if
you're a fan of the batman it's the
latest riddle posted online by director
matt reeves giving us everything we
hoped for and visually confirming that
barry kyogen played the clown prince of
crime himself the joker posting to
twitter last night reeves shared a
teaser still of the scene along with the
site
ratsaalada.com which asked fans to
decipher three riddles in order to
access the deleted scene and if you were
able to crack the code
you got this
[Music]
that's chillin after the scene's
released barry took to twitter writing
honestly i am stuck for words but i'm
very very blessed to play this role
after the amazing amazing actors before
me here's my version enjoy all right so
if you haven't seen the film spoilers
ahead obviously for everyone slightly
confused by that last scene in arkham
asylum we now know for sure that paul
danos the riddler was talking to the
joker in an adjacent cell we have
confirmed to variety during an interview
back in february that the scene was
initially to be in the film coming after
batman first discovers the riddler has
killed the gotham city police
commissioner he wants to know what makes
a serial killer tick and so he goes to
the most twisted mind he knows the joker
who he found out was committed to arkham
a year prior
first anniversary
is paper
what makes you think i'm so cheap
revealing why the scene was cut from the
film reeves said it was just one of
those things where in the course of the
movie what that scene was doing other
scenes were also doing and so we didn't
need the scene but as a standalone a
scene is very eerie and creepy and cool
next little puzzles disney
so ridiculous
and keep me playing this whole life
yeah you bet thanks to ryu's pension for
mood lighting fans never really got a
good look at the
unseen arkham prisoner in the film and
judging from the scene we just saw
he looks pretty rough far more
disfigured in the scar than other
cinematic versions of the villain you
can still make out the green hair and
that sadistic smile
reeves has cited that he and makeup
artist mike mourinho pulled visual cues
from the phantom of the opera and the
original inspiration for the joker
conrad bites performance in the 1928
silent film the man who laughs the
director also confirmed that in this
universe joker suffers from a real
congenital disease called angel man
syndrome where a person can't stop
smiling saying to variety that the
psychological suffering of a child who
was born with that condition could
inevitably lead them to have a
nihilistic take on the world
so yes fans were right when they
questioned those outdoor gotham city
hall scenes where kyogen was said to be
playing officer stanley merkel and yes
you were all right to question the
reason behind having prosthetics master
mike marino handling makeup for the
penguin and someone cited as you know
unseen arkham prisoner and yes you were
definitely right when we questioned why
reeves would cast kyogen as a random
throwaway character unfortunately none
of that means there are any plans for
the supervillain to show up in the
rumored sequels to the batman reeves
confirmed in his interview with variety
that the joker riddler meets creep and
the film is not an easter egg scene
adding i have no idea when or if we
would return to that character in the
movies
any theories
[Music]
so what do you think after all that with
that chilling performance do you think
it would be a waste to not bring barry
back or do you think this is all another
fake red herring thing to satisfy fans
but throw them off track as always drop
your thoughts in the comments below and
i'll see you next week for moonlight
you